[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportages sur Public Sénat 90 minutes
pour prendre du recul sur l'actualité
pour lui donner du sens aussi grâce à
nos invités experts et voici le sommaire
de ce 28 mars la mobilisation étant
baisse pour la 10e journée d'action
contre la réforme des retraites la grève
des éboueurs est également suspendus à
Paris à partir de demain mais personne
d'entrevoit devrait sortie de crise pour
l'instant l'intersydicale a proposé une
médiation refusée par le gouvernement
compte tenu de la mobilisation qui ne
faiblit pas comme on l'a décidé en inter
syndicale
on a proposé une nouvelle fois au
gouvernement et surtout au président de
la République de suspendre son projet et
de nommer une médiation la posture
inflexible du président de la République
le fait dévisser dans le baromètre odoxa
mascara que nous révélerons dans
quelques minutes peut-on dévoilera aussi
ce que les Français pensent de
l'hypothèse d'une dissolution de
l'Assemblée et puis dans trois quarts
d'heure je vous propose un débat
volontairement décalé de l'actualité du
jour une semaine après la rencontre
Poutine à Moscou on analysera la
solidité de cet axe sinorus on verra si
la Chine peut jouer un rôle de médiateur
en Ukraine et puis à une semaine de sa
visite d'État à Pékin on verra quel
message Emmanuel Macron peut faire
passer au président chinois mais d'abord
notre reportage au cœur de la
manifestation parisienne avec Jonathan
Dupriez et Adrien
journée dans la rue une inter syndicale
plus soudée que jamais mais un
gouvernement toujours sourd aux
revendications des centrales pour sortir
de l'impasse les leaders syndicaux
Laurent Berger en tête ont appelé
l'exécutif à lancer une médiation idée
immédiatement balayé par le gouvernement
depuis le 19 janvier on est dans des
mobilisations qui sont exceptionnelles
encore il y a seulement quelques jours
et on nous dit mais non on n'a pas
besoin de ça de se parler on n'a pas
besoin de médiation c'est une
proposition qui vient de la terre
syndicale elle est formulée depuis à
peine trois heures et il y a déjà un
refus donc c'est bien qu'on a besoin de
de se parler mais on n'arrive pas à se
parler en tête de cortège le mot d'ordre
reste le même retirez la réforme les
syndicats on appelle ainsi à la
responsabilité du chef de l'État face à
un pays qui plonge chaque jour un peu
plus dans la crise on espère
qu'aujourd'hui que le Président de la
République va avoir un sursaut de
lucidité parce que il peut pas prétendre
en faisant des fausses mains tendues qui
se transforment jour après jour en gif
contre le mouvement social donc j'espère
que vraiment il va réaliser il ne peut
pas gouverner gouverner contre son
propre pays si la mobilisation est en
baisse dans les rues de la capitale 450
000 manifestants selon la CGT certains
sont toujours très remontés contre le
président de la République qu'il tienne
pour unique responsable d'une réforme
passée en force il y a un vrai problème
on a peu de tout écouter que le
gouvernement
je suis juste un train sans aucune
réflexion une réfléchit pas il en a rien
à [__] il est dans une espèce de de
logique économique purement financière
avec un déni global de la réalité que
ville a pu faire des gens au côté des
manifestants des sénateurs de gauche à
tente de pied ferme la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel et une
éventuelle censure de la réforme des
retraites mais il reste trois semaines
avant que les sages ne rende leur
décision une éternité au vu du climat
social sur la censure
[Musique]
mais effectivement
l'horizon est trop lointain donc il faut
avoir des actes politiques avant
toujours très déterminé l'Inter syndical
devrait décider ce soir d'une nouvelle
journée d'action dans les prochains
jours
on analyse donc on tire le bilan de
cette dixième journée mobilisation et on
vous révèle dans un instant le baromètre
odoxam mascara je vous présente mes
invités Nathalie Moret bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes journaliste politique pour le
groupe de presse régionale et bras
Laurent fagerman bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes sociologue historien spécialiste
des mouvements sociaux chercheurs
associés au centre de recherche sur les
liens sociaux de l'Université Paris
cités Céline brag bonsoir bienvenue à
vous vous êtes directrice générale
d'odoxize vous allez nous révéler donc
les résultats de ce baromètre c'est pour
le public Sénat et la PQR c'est un
baromètre mensuel et vous êtes vous ou
galiman présent ici chaque mois
évidemment et il y a aussi avec nous
ifs sensi qui est en duplex en
visioconférence Seigneur partenaire chez
mascaret bonsoir bienvenue vous analysez
les réseaux sociaux dans le cadre de ce
baromètre on viendra vers vous
régulièrement pendant ce débat et
j'accueille également il me disent
appelle ce qui bonsoir Émilie bienvenue
vous êtes spécialiste en communication
politique et éditorise pour sens
publique peut-être une analyse un peu
générale de cette
de cette dixième journée de mobilisation
Nathalie Moret il y a les chiffres il y
a une baisse assez générale qui est
presque une baisse de moitié dans le
cortège parisien si l'on en croit pour
l'instant à l'heure où je vous parle les
seuls chiffres que l'on a sur la CGT et
pourtant c'est peut-être une baisse en
trompe l'oeil vous voyez ça c'est
difficile à analyser c'est pas pour
autant un mouvement qui s'essouffre
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire on peut en
dire que c'est la dixième journée de
mobilisation et que ce qu'on peut voir
dans les cortèges aujourd'hui n'a rien à
voir avec ce qu'on pouvait voir il y a
deux mois le 19 janvier le 19 janvier
les gens étaient très remontés contre le
fait de de repousser l'âge légal de la
retraite c'était vraiment dans les
cortèges on voyait vraiment des gens
très motivés très syndiqués qui étaient
opposé à cette réforme et qui la
déchiffrer parfaitement bien aujourd'hui
c'est plus du tout le cas c'est-à-dire
qu'effectivement il y a moins de
personnes mais ça c'est assez logique
parce que effectivement ça coûte cher de
faire grève ça coûte cher de de poser
une journée comme ça et d'aller manif
mais surtout c'est pas vraiment le même
public il y a toujours le public du
départ mais il y a aussi un public plus
politisé c'était d'abord un politique un
public très syndical et maintenant c'est
très politisé début janvier on voyait
beaucoup de pancarte contre la première
ministre aujourd'hui la première
ministre elle est plus du tout dans les
slogans c'est ce sont des manifestations
qui sont plus politiques au sens où
elles sont vraiment tournées contre le
président Macron contre le 49-3 et son
utilisation contre oui vraiment une
manifestation beaucoup plus politique
avec plus de jeunes et c'est en cela ou
c'est plus difficile pour l'exécutif
c'est plus difficile à atteindre il y a
eu très clairement un avant et un après
49-3 Laurent fragerman est-ce que le
fait qu'il y a un peu moins de monde
c'est peut-être lié moi je tente cette
analyse aux violences de des dernières
manifestations est-ce que des gens qui
se disent on y va pas parce qu'il y a eu
des violences la dernière fois alors il
y a plusieurs indicateurs en fait pour
une journée de mobilisation c'est les
manifestations bien sûr et là votre
interprétation ça fait partie évidemment
de qui sont plausibles et il y a les
grèves donc on voit par exemple dans
l'éducation nationale un recul moi j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur les chiffres de
grève dans ce secteur je peux congeler
les éléments pour dire que les chiffres
du ministère ne sont pas les bons on
n'entrera pas dans le débat mais cela
dit clairement il y a un recul par
rapport à la dernière journée parce que
je pense que la raison principale c'est
aussi pareil dans les transports etc
c'est que les gens se projettent sur
encore à certains temps alors que après
cette mars le discours ambiance qu'on
entendait beaucoup c'était quand même
l'idée bon c'est la fin et d'ailleurs
les reportages on voyait des
manifestants en disant non non on va
aller jusqu'au retrait mais ils avaient
l'air de se convaincre même je trouve
que l'ambiance n'est pas tout à fait la
même aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
maintenant les gens se disent il y a
peut-être une chance et après tout
pourquoi pas essayer le Conseil
constitutionnel ou si on se pouvoir est
fragile donc il faut maintenir la
pression donc on anticipe va falloir en
faire d'autres des journées
un peu moins importante alors je fais la
prochaine ou monsieur Macron fait encore
une boulette et alors là ça donne un
nouveau carburant par exemple là
franchement le reçu l'attitude d'Olivier
Véran on en parlera peut être
susceptible de renforcer la prochaine
mobilisation on parlera évidemment de
cette proposition de médiation mais un
tout petit peu plus tard dans ce débat
parce que c'est une vraie qu'on commence
à révéler on va pas tout faire d'un bloc
on va faire un peu morceau par morceau
c'est ce qui est intéressant on le
disait avec Nathalie Moray il y a un
changement de de nature presque du
mouvement et un Emmanuel Macron qui est
clairement ciblé pour on va dire la
pratique du pouvoir ça se ressent sur sa
popularité à remettre puisque là il
dévisse clairement puisqu'il perd 6
points en un mois aujourd'hui
70% des Français estiment que c'est un
mauvais président de la République tous
les Français se positionnent
c'est-à-dire on a la 70% qui disent
qu'il est mauvais 30% qui nous disent
que c'est un bon président et si vous
voulez on voit que cette réforme des
retraites c'est vraiment ce qui provoque
cette chute c'est à dire qu'il a baissé
de 11 fois depuis l'annonce de cette
réforme et là il perd beaucoup suite
49-3 qui aurait pu avoir un gros impact
sur Elizabeth borne et en effet c'est
lui qui prend surtout ses points en moi
et puis aussi suite à son interview
c'est à dire que l'interview elle a
vraiment mis de l'huile sur le feu c'est
à dire que l'idée que le président
explique il continue ce chemin que la
réforme suive son chemin démocratique je
sais plus s'il a utilisé ces mots
vincettes interview mais ça c'est les
mots qui avaient été
là et
et donc ça ça a vraiment pas plu
d'ailleurs on avait fait un sondage
juste après les trois quarts des
Français considéraient que il est pas du
tout compris le peuple français et il y
avait 6 points de français en plus qui
disaient ok maintenant on soutient les
manifestants donc si on a une baisse du
soutien dans la rue on voit que
l'opinion française elle a tendance
plutôt à se renforcer derrière les
manifestants et à considérer que et bien
si violence il y a si blocages il y a
c'est vraiment de la responsabilité du
gouvernement ce qui fait que ça piège
quand même
l'exécutif parce que aujourd'hui on
considère que tout problème tout
renforcement ce sera essentiellement de
la faute du gouvernement et pas des
manifestations
des trésors de TF1 et France 2 la
posture qui avait eu à Emmanuel Macron
vis-à-vis de Marine Le Pen je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez dans
l'entre-deux-tours
j'essaie d'avance que vous allez me dire
et je le dis un petit peu d'une manière
dilettante je suis là le langage du
corps
donné un peu ce sentiment là il y avait
des mots en effet très fort parce
qu'au-delà de l'idée dire on continue
cheminement démocratique il y avait on
va continuer à marche forcer on va se
passer du Parlement il y a beaucoup trop
de lois dans ce pays donc on va donc on
sentait cette Emmanuel Macron qui veut
se passer des syndicats du Parlement des
élus comme d'habitude en quelque sorte
et c'était une fin de non-recevoir je
pense aussi ce que ce qui a joué dans
les manifestations aujourd'hui ce qui
peut jouer c'est le la violence c'est
vrai qu'il y a eu beaucoup de violence
ces derniers temps de manifestation mais
on a eu aussi des images et des sons de
violences du côté des policiers dont on
ne connaît pas forcément toujours le
contexte sauf certains éléments
puisqu'on a eu des audio quand même très
clairement il y a des enquêtes en cours
et ça ça peut jouer aussi notamment sur
la population jeune qui a rejoint les
rangs des manifestants évidemment sur
cette question des violences mais je
voudrais donner à parole une première
fois à Yves sons si pour rester sur la
thématique de de la popularité du
président de la République
ustensil vous avez évidemment vu il est
il est de nouveau au centre de toutes
les attentions on peut dire ça comme ça
oui clairement c'est à dire que
évidemment on peut comprendre que le sa
popularité est baissée les chiffres que
donne donc ça sont
effectivement catastrophiques mais on a
un narratif c'est à dire que le
président était resté relativement
absent des débats au fond jusqu'au 49.3
et le narratif qui s'est mis en place à
ce moment-là qui est un peu changé la
donne
vraiment montrer que cette décision
avait été orchestrée à l'Elysée et
lui-même a reconcentré toute décision
finale sur lui-même en fixant le Conseil
constitutionnel uniquement un arbitre et
là sur les volumes des conversations sur
Internet on voit une explosion qui est
en record d'ailleurs et qui est
effectivement très négatif
et qui vient
enquister tous les toutes les critiques
qui avaient avant les critiques qui
étaient faites sur la méthode sur
Elizabeth borne tout est reporté sur
Emmanuel Macron le manque d'écoute le
manque de dialogue est reporté sur
Emmanuel Macron également et là on voit
qu'il se passe quelque chose c'est à
dire que à partir du moment où la
critique est sur l'absence de dialogue
c'est à dire que sur Internet dans les
conversations il y a une contestation du
fait qui aurait eu cheminement
démocratique c'est à dire qu'en gros le
débat démocratique n'aurait pas eu lieu
et la réaction de l'exécutif est une
réaction d'autorité dans une attente de
dialogue et évidemment les critiques sur
la police qui sont très fortes en tout
cas sur les réseaux sociaux on y
reviendra plus tard pas pardon
IV et ce sera je préfère que vous disiez
pas tout maintenant et on y reviendra un
peu plus tard peut-être un point pour
conclure sur ce premier point il y a la
question de la légitimité qu'on n'a pas
qu'on a beaucoup entendu il y a aucune
critique sur la légitimité
institutionnelle du président par contre
on voit que cette légitimité
institutionnelle est fortement
contaminée par une très puissante
dynamique de délégitimation politique et
je suis pas sûr que l'exécutif les perçu
Nathalie Moret est-ce qu'il y a une
inquiétude ou peut-être même plus une
sorte de de colère c'est les
sympathisants du prénom République chez
les militants Renaissance absolument et
c'est même assez nouveau ça m'a été
remonté par plusieurs députés
Renaissance qui effectivement ont vu
leur leur sympathisants leurs militants
sur place être enfin avoir un
retournement par rapport à cette réforme
des retraites justement après le 49-3
c'est-à-dire la réforme oui la réforme
des retraites ok on peut soutenir le
49-3 non et ça ça a été vraiment un
tournant que mon dit plusieurs
plusieurs députés Renaissance et
j'attire votre attention sur la partiel
qui a lieu dans l'Ariège ou la candidate
Renaissance non seulement n'est pas au
deuxième tour mais en plus la quasiment
pas fait campagne les 15 derniers jours
parce qu'elle savait que elle aurait
mauvaise presse à distribuer ces tracts
donc on voit bien que sur le terrain il
y a une forte remise en cause du chef de
l'État qui se ressent et qui est relayée
par les militants et ça ça pose la
question de la dissolution il viendra
dans dans un instant et je voudrais
qu'on parle de cette médiation proposée
par l'Inter syndicale et puis avant ça
une information de de cette fin
d'après-midi et je voudrais vous
entendre là-dessus Laurent fragermain
parce qu'on est dans un contexte
particulier à la CGT on est dans un
contexte de renouvellement puisque
Philippe Martin ne peut pas se
représenter on a appris en cette fin
d'après-midi il faut que j'essaye de
retour de retrouver la dépêche que le
bilan de la majorité sortante avait été
mis en minorité figurez-vous ce qui est
ce qui laisse augurer voilà la direction
sortante mise en minorité sur son bilan
50,32% des suffrages exprimés contre le
rapport c'est un peu faut pas qu'on soit
trop trop technique non plus mais
qu'est-ce que ça laisse augurer parce
qu'il y a un il y a un duel pour la
succession de Philippe Martinez
qui a un débat démocratique
au moins là je pense peut-être pour être
à contre-courant quand même que les
différences entre les camps ne sont pas
si forte énormes que ça faut pas les
exagérer maintenant c'est clair qu'il y
a des visions différentes en plus il y a
des candidats de opposés et que voilà le
Congrès est l'occasion de se de cette
affrontement ça peut être une catharsis
là effectivement Philippe Martignas
commence mal son congrès si il perd déjà
ce d'autant que ce vote ne sanctionne
pas seulement ça personne il sanctionne
aussi toute la direction sortante y
compris Céline vers zelletti
porte-parole de la direction donc on
sait effectivement un élément dans le
débat alors c'est c'est
Céline Verzeletti qui est dans le camp
Martinez ou c'est vous savez deux
candidats de principales
donc c'est universeleti alors c'est un
peu compliqué mais disons elle est
pressentie par plusieurs fédérations
importantes donc c'est une opposition
qui n'est pas la candidate de
merci parce que
je voulais vous faire dire
donc il y a un de louvert on va dire
vous voulez que je vous en parle allez-y
d'accord je pense d'abord quelle grande
différence entre parce qu'il y en a
quand même la première c'est sur la
gouvernance c'est-à-dire comment la CGT
doit être dirigée et il y a eu vraiment
une forte critique quand Philippe
Martinez avec Marie buisson notamment a
mis en place une alliance écologique et
sociale avec des associations
environnementales Greenpeace les émis de
la terre etc ce qui donc ce qui était
très contesté c'est que dans le projet
initial il y avait la critique du
nucléaire alors pour la fédération de
l'énergie le nucléaire enfin la CGT
c'était quand même surprenant qu'on y
est songé au sein de la confédération et
ça attriste et le fait la manière de
procéder finalement pour prendre la
défense parce que j'ai pas évidemment
pas à prendre position il faut quand
même comprendre que à la CGT le pouvoir
est surtout dans des fédérations
profession les mineurs mineurs n'existe
plus malheureusement mais les cheminots
etc et la Confédération était assez
fragile faible donc vous avez un
secrétaire général qu'on voit dans les
médias mais qui en réalité à peu de prix
sur son organisation qui est extrêmement
décentralisé donc à un moment donné on
peut imaginer que Philippe Martinez ait
eu envie de faire les choses mais ça a
été mal vu premier point je serai pas
long le second point c'est c'est
vraiment cette est-ce qu'on va mettre
plus d'initiative d'argent de pouvoir
dans les unions locales parce qu'on a
des milliers 80 000 syndiqués qui ne
sont pas organisés dans les fédérations
qui sont nulle part on a un problème
d'organisation très fort à la CGT ou
est-ce que les fédérations dont je
parlais sont le cœur c'est un peu ça le
débat aussi et alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que on peut aussi se
dire que ça ça laisse un peu plus la
main à un Laurent Berger et on va on va
aujourd'hui grâce à vous Émilie
s'intéressait à celui qui apparaît un
peu comme la star du mouvement
de lutte contre la ferme des syndicats
en ce moment la semaine dernière Laurent
Berger donc leader de la CFDT il a
proposé de mettre sur pause la réforme
des retraites pendant 6 mois pour
apaiser les choses je le cite il a dit
on a mis la charrue avant les bœufs tout
le monde le sait c'était sur RTL il a
réitéré sa proposition aujourd'hui ce
matin sur France Inter en proposant même
un délire raccourci de la pose il dit un
mois un mois et demi et en précisant un
petit peu cette médiation ça serait une
deux trois personnes qui irait voir
chacune des parties prenantes au
dialogue en tout cas au conflit et alors
très vite le gouvernement a donné sa
réponse par la voix d'Olivier Véran à la
suite du Conseil des ministres il n'y a
pas véritablement de grosses surprises
on écoute tout de suite on va pas
forcément besoin de médiation pour se
parler on peut se parler directement le
président de la République l'a dit il
est prêt à recevoir l'intersydical dès
lors parce que nous respectons nos
institutions que le Conseil
constitutionnel se sera prononcé sur la
conformité de notre contexte de loi
ensuite la première ministre se tient à
disposition des syndicats pour les
recevoir très directement pour pouvoir
parler en gros le porte-parole répète
l'argument de son président la porte
reste ouverte au syndicat pour discuter
de tout sauf de l'essentiel quasiment du
sujet qui fâche c'est à dire les 64 ans
alors que c'est la condition pour les
syndicats d'un redémarrage des
discussions on a vu quand même je dois
dire un olivier Véran qui était très
embêté par rapport aux relances qui ont
été multiples un des journalistes il
était même agacé par cette question
répétitive qui revenait tout le temps et
tout à l'heure on l'a vu au milieu de ça
Laurent Berger lui a tout de suite
répondu au milieu des manifestants on
l'écoute ça va commencer à suffire les
fins de non-recevoir à discussion au
dialogue il va falloir s'interroger sur
qui ne veut pas le dialogue il suffit
pas de dire partout on veut le dialogue
mais on veut pas discuter par exemple
des retraites c'est pas possible
regardez ce qui se passe derrière nous
comment vous voulez qu'on aille discuter
si on peut pas parler des retraites dans
cette période
alors il faut dire que cette idée fait
tout doucement son chemin malgré le
refus du gouvernement en témoigne les
propos de Jean-Paul Mattei le président
du groupe modem à l'Assemblée nationale
donc membre de la majorité
présidentielle lors d'un point presse à
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui il a
fait savoir que les députés centristes
n'étaient pas contre ce mode de dialogue
pour avoir un certain recul retrouver du
lien et arriver à se parler alors si on
reste sur le thème de la communication
politique est-ce que Laurent Berger
serait pas en train de voler un peu la
vedette à Emmanuel Macron mais c'est
vrai que depuis le début du précédent
quinquennat est là on a toujours vu on a
eu l'habitude de voir ce jeune président
trouver à chaque fois la parade à chaque
crise le grand débat national pour les
gilets jaunes le quoiqu'il en coûte pour
la crise covid et là cette fois-ci rien
du tout si ce n'est une charge contre
les républicains qui à l'Assemblée
nationale n'ont pas pu voter la réforme
et du coup ça amené aux 49,3 et
maintenant contre LFI soupçonné de
vouloir faire tomber les institutions
pire le président de la République
apparaît ces derniers jours comme
retranché dans son bunker il a annulé
son déplacement demain à Toulon c'était
sur le service national universel il n'a
pas pu recevoir en le sait Charles III
qui devait arriver dimanche en France et
il a même dû annuler ses plus
anecdotique mais quand même sa venue au
Stade de France vendredi dernier le
match de France de foot effectivement
elle tenable ça combien de temps ça peut
tenir parce que la majorité de la
population française les syndicales
l'opposition maintenant une partie de sa
majorité vous en parliez tout à l'heure
aussi pour les militants réclament un
retour en arrière et une discussion plus
apaisée le gouvernement souhaite en fait
tenir jusqu'à la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel histoire de laisser ce
fameux cheminement démocratique pour le
texte et puis que ça passe qu'on passe à
autre chose mais ce sera pas avant le
mi-avril et c'est encore très loin alors
il y a beaucoup de thèmes sur lesquels
on va revenir merci Émilie il y a la
question de la sortie de crise et des
options pour la sortie de crise et puis
il y a aussi cette proposition de
médiation peut-être avec vous Nathalie
Moret pour commencer comment vous
expliquer la rapidité de la de la
réaction de d'Olivier Véran ils ont
voulu fermer tout de suite enfin ça
renforce effectivement ce on voit bien
peut-être qu'ils l'ont perçu comme un
piège une pause c'est un enterrement de
première classe enfin on imagine bien la
réflexion qui a pu qui a pu se faire
mais comment vous l'analysez vous moi je
vais vous faire une réponse un peu en
même temps je comprends que le président
dise c'est pas possible on est dans le
cheminement démocratique etc Il garant
des institutions et les institutions
veulent veulent que quand un texte est
devant le Conseil constitutionnel et ben
c'est le président reste en retrait ça
je le comprends et je comprends ce qu'il
veut dire l'autre version du en même
temps c'est qu'on est dans une situation
particulière il faut pas oublier qu'il a
écrit il y a 5 ans ou 6 ans maintenant
un livre qui s'appelle révolution en
disant qu'il fallait justement arrêter
de de que toutes les choses soient
corsetées et ça ce président pragmatique
ça a toujours été le président du
pragmatisme il devrait l'entendre et en
disant on est dans une situation où
effectivement au regard des chiffres par
exemple du du baromètre doxa aujourd'hui
je ne suis plus entendu je ne suis plus
possible et il faut bouger aujourd'hui y
compris les gens dans sa majorité lui
disent qu'il faut faire un bougie il y a
des gens dans sa majorité qui sont très
divisés y compris dans son entourage
proche mais pour l'instant son entourage
le plus proche
Alexis colère pour ne pas le nommer et
plutôt dans la position non il faut que
tu sois garantie de l'Élysée il faut que
tu sois garant des institutions et tu et
que tu gardes cette cette position très
ferme et inflexible combien de temps ça
peut durer c'est ça la vraie question
c'est une braque alors c'est vraiment un
enseignement passionnant de du baromètre
d'oxam mascara les Français ils existent
ils veulent une sortie de crise ils
veulent que qu'on fasse quelque chose
quoi en quelque sorte là pour être
honnête on a testé des sorties de crise
justement qui fonctionnent enfin qui
sont possibles dans nos institutions
même si les Français ils sont comme
disait en fait ils étouffent un peu dans
ses institutions ils aimeraient bien
qu'on trouve d'autres solutions mais on
a testé notamment la dissolution et on a
une majorité très nette de français 61%
de Français qui nous disent oui on
j'aimerais que Emmanuel Macron puisse
dissoudre l'Assemblée nationale et ça
pratiquement toutes les sympathisants
des différents partis politiques sont
d'accord y compris les sympathisants LR
à une majorité un peu symbolique mais
pas tant que ça 51 versus 45 finalement
à part les sympathisants de renaissance
qui eux sont vraiment braqués contre
cette dissolution parce qu'il voit bien
ce que ça pourrait donner comme résultat
les autres disent bah tiens pourquoi pas
on a testé aussi l'idée du référendum
d'initiative partagée le riz enfin qui a
un nom un peu horrible quand on le
résume et bien là aussi les Français
il faut un certain nombre de députés qui
saisissent le Conseil constitutionnel
et ensuite il faudra si le Conseil dit
ok allez-y 10% du corps électoral voilà
ce qui représente presque 5 millions de
Français on peut se dire qu'à priori les
5 millions français qui vont voter par
internet
on est pour le risque
signer pour être voilà pour valider ce
référendum et puis qu'après
a priori il y a vraiment un souhait très
fort des Français que ce processus qui a
déjà été entamé puisqu'il a été envoyé
au Conseil constitutionnel par les
commentaires puissent suivre son chemin
puisqu'on a 71% qui voudraient que ce
référendum d'un milieu on a 75% des
Français qui nous disent nous on
participerait bien à ce référendum et on
peut imaginer que ce référendum là il
fonctionnerait l'idée serait de dire il
faut pas repousser l'âge légal au-delà
des 62 ans et on a 67% d'entre eux qui
voteraient pour l'annulation du report
de l'âge légal de départ au-delà de 62
ans bref à travers ces deux questions on
voit qu'on a des Français qui se disent
d'accord mais là il faudrait que
l'exécutif bouge trouve une solution ne
nous laisse pas encore dans cette
situation qui a tendance à dégénérer il
faut bien le dire sauf F que ces deux
solutions elles sont potentiellement
enfin German politiquement même
néfaste pour le camp présidentiel on
prend la dissolution aussi on prend le
référendum de toute façon ils perdra
ça m'étonnerait qu'on ait une victoire
de renaissance en cas de dissolution
bref il peut toujours retirer son projet
c'est rapide ça se fait en quelques
heures il suffit pas de publier les
décrets d'application et de l'annoncer
on a déjà eu Jacques Chirac la fait à
plusieurs reprises sur plusieurs thèmes
plus fondamentalement je pense que par
rapport à l'idée de pause il y a
effectivement l'idée aussi du côté des
syndicats de chercher une sortie de
crise est-ce que Laurent Berger appelé
des voix de passage tout à l'heure et ça
c'est important à mon avis parce que
finalement aussi bien CGT que CFDT ont
bien conscience que les dernières
décennies les grands mouvements sociaux
ont été mal gérés à la fin c'est-à-dire
ils ont ils ont ils ont réussi à en
lancer mais ils ont pas réussi à les
terminer du côté de la CFDT c'est parce
que bah ils ont ils ont négocié à chaud
ils ont été accusés de trahison ils ont
perdu des adhérents ils ont perdu en
images c'était des astres donc de ce
point de vue là Laurent Berger réalise
un sans faute par rapport François
cherech c'est-à-dire qui réussit à la
fois lancer des initiatives et à garder
l'unité syndicale qui était son
prédécesseur à la tête de Monsieur je
dis par exemple au tout début quand il y
a eu cette idée de alors je finis sur la
CGT du côté de la CGT ils ont lancé ils
ont animé des mouvements très puissants
je pense par exemple à la loi la loi
travail à une connerie en 2016 sauf que
à un moment donné ça s'est effiloché et
manifestation après manifestation ils
n'ont rien négocié et rien obtenu donc
l'enjeu pour les syndicats c'est de
prouver aux Français qui peuvent obtenir
quelque chose c'est ça je pense qu'ils
ont besoin au moins de dire on a gagné
des choses dans les faits ils ont déjà
gagné des choses par le biais de la
pression sur les députés de droits des
négociations qui ont lieu au début
c'était 65 ans après c'était 64 mais ça
c'est pas tellement perceptible en
termes de communication ce serait quand
même mieux d'obtenir des choses plus
concrètes ils ont juste obtenu
l'annulation d'une visite royale à Paris
quoi vous risquez
si on fait le bilan il y a eu que ça
j'en suis pas convaincu je pense que
déjà avant je pense que par le rapport
de force qu'il crée c'est à dire que
c'est pas simplement on est toujours
polarisé sur les bras de fer mais
l'action syndicale c'est toute l'année
et d'ailleurs tournez le dos syndicat ça
pose un problème pour toute la suite
c'est à dire pendant 4 ans encore
Emmanuel Macron il va devoir travailler
avec ses syndicats qu'ils veulent ou non
ils ont montré qu'ils savaient s'unir
aussi ce qui était complètement sorti de
on n'avait pas vu ça depuis une bonne
dizaine d'années
alors ce que j'entends derrière ce que
vous dites d'ailleurs ça fait partie de
de du package des propositions faite par
l'Inter syndical c'est l'espèce on
pourrait appeler ça une grande
conférence sociale tel immoré c'était on
met sur pause on lance une grosse
conférence sociale on quand on dit on
aurait dû quand Laurent Berger dit on a
fait les choses à l'envers c'était on
commence par parler du travail de la
répartition de la richesse du sens du
travail toutes ces questions qui sont
des questions centrales que les Français
se posent depuis deux ou trois ans et
qui aurait effectivement
là je vous rejoins peut-être pu être
posé avant de se dire on va travailler
plus quoi c'est vrai mais l'agenda du
gouvernement il était différent
c'est vrai que ça peut paraître logique
mais en même temps le fait de travailler
plus dans l'optique du gouvernement ça
veut dire produire plus de richesses et
produire plus de richesse c'est trouver
de l'argent non seulement pour
l'équation retraite mais pour trouver de
l'argent pour l'hôpital pour l'éducation
pour pour les pour tout ce qui est fait
et ce qui fait que que les Français ont
aussi des motifs d'inquiétude donc ça a
été un discours qu'on peut entendre nous
interromptionner notre modèle social il
faut produire ça n'a pas du tout été
présenté comme ça dans un premier temps
dans un premier temps ça a été dans la
ça a été 65 ans point et c'est comme ça
parce que c'est comme ça partout etc
donc je pense qu'il y a eu vraiment un
déficit de pédagogie y compris de la
part de la première ministre parce que
quand elle a présenté son projet elle a
dit voilà je vous présente un projet qui
est juste c'est juste impossible de dire
ça quand vous demandez aux gens de
travailler deux ans de plus si elle
avait dit d'entrée c'est ça parce qu'on
va
sauvegarder notre modèle social
peut-être que l'équation aurait été
différent
donc il a rechangé enfin tout ça a été
mal phagoté depuis le départ c'est aussi
dire est-ce que c'est une loi que les
Français croient encore dans la capacité
d'Emmanuel Macron à réformer le pays a
aussi cette question dans le baromètre
alors là si son du coup ça c'est
sûr du 55 ans et en fait ce qui croit le
plus c'est ceux qui sont évidemment le
plus proche d'Emmanuel Macron par leurs
idées c'est-à-dire plutôt les
sympathisants Renaissance voir les
sympathisants et l'air qui se disent
donc ce sont des gens qui disent c'est
encore possible et qui veulent croire
que c'est encore possible
dans ce 50/50 on a des gens qui le
disent moi qui sont ses adversaires mais
qui le disent aussi un peu c'est aussi
ça qui expliquait ce 55 ans parce qu'on
pourrait se dire au fond comment on peut
encore avoir 50% de gens qui se disent
ça vu la le bazar du moment bah en fait
les gens se disent ok il y a du bazar ok
ok il y a beaucoup de manifestations on
est tous contre cette réforme mais le
président de la République il a pas
l'air de vouloir changer d'avis et
j'appellerai pas du tout ça de la
résignation puisque j'ai entendu
beaucoup ce mot
je trouve que ça correspond pas du tout
du tout à l'état d'esprit qu'on relève
dans l'opinion on a des gens qui
pouvaient se dire oui en effet il va
finir par faire passer l'âge légal à 64
ans mais qui qui était en colère en fait
de cette de cette décision là qui va à
l'encontre de ce que pense la majorité
des gens donc voilà ça aujourd'hui il y
a beaucoup de gens qui se disent il va
peut-être continuer à faire ses réformes
mais nous on le soutiendra pas oui juste
une une remarque sur la fameuse
dissolution en fait et d'ailleurs
Emmanuel Macron on joue pas tellement
mais il y a pas d'alternatives
politiques dans cette dissolution ce
qu'on entend dire par rapport au sondage
c'est que peut-être le RN le
rassemblement national gagnerait
quelques députés Renaissance en perdre
un peu la nuit Pesse on gagnerait un
tout petit peu mais globalement ça ne ça
ne dessinerait pas une nouvelle majorité
capable de porter ses idées là plus loin
et je pense que dans cette résignation
ou dans ce fatalisme ou cette idée un
petit peu il y a probablement ça chez
les Françaises et les Français ils ne
voient pas leurs idées portées
politiquement il y a aussi peut-être
parce qu'on parle de dissolution on
parle de de
on va dire la vitalité de notre
démocratie ça aussi c'est ressorti dans
dans les médias sociaux dans les réseaux
sociaux ce mois-ci sous quelle forme
alors moi je dirais que
la contestation est vraiment concentrée
sur la méthode associée à cette réforme
avec évidemment le la contestation sur
la manière de faire des manuels Macron
c'est à dire c'est très situationnel en
fait contrairement à ce qu'on a beaucoup
entendu ce qui peut expliquer que
finalement les possibilités de gérer par
la suite sont plutôt ouvertes c'est sur
cette cette situation que cette on va
dire que les Français sont braqués
ce qu'ils entendent du Président c'est
vos arguments sont irrecevables et vos
émotions sont inappropriées
ce qui est le cocktail pour créer
évidemment des réactions non pas
violentes mais en nous c'est ce qu'on a
qualifié de réactions militantes
c'est-à-dire que autant on va dire qu'il
y a une sorte de ramollissement des
discussions autour de la retraite mais
une activation très forte
qui est plus politique et donc qui
laisse penser que on aurait un niveau de
tension qui va se poursuivre
peut-être un peu sur les populations un
peu plus resserrées Nathalie la
dissolution c'est très très bas dans le
fait dans la pile des hypothèses du
président de la République pour les
raisons qu'elle vient d'indiquer
c'est-à-dire qu'une dissolution c'est en
général quand un prison président
dissout c'est qu'il espère d'avoir une
majorité plus forte là ça me paraît très
très compliqué c'est une arme qu'il
brandit comme une menace mais dans les
faits je pense que ça serait très
compliqué pour lui intervenir oui par
rapport aux sentiments de mépris ou
c'est très important ça c'est ce que le
philosophe Axel honnête appelle la
société de la reconnaissance c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui peut être un
carburant on l'a déjà vu avec le 49-3 il
y avait par exemple quand Xavier darkos
ministre de l'Éducation avait dit que
les les professeurs de maternelle
changer les couches de leurs élèves ça
avait été un formidable carburant pour
des grèves à ce moment-là donc il y a
vraiment je pense que c'est quelque
chose les émotions justement que le
gouvernement a tort de minimiser où ils
ont tort d'avoir cette attitude alors on
va parler maintenant et ça va être notre
dernier chapitre de la question des
conséquences on va dire politique des
violences et je propose à Quentin calmer
de nous rejoindre bonsoir Quentin
bienvenue sur ce plateau depuis
plusieurs jours et on va parler là de de
la stratégie des forces de l'ordre il y
a une unité qui concentre les critiques
la brave m alors c'est quoi la brave m
alors la brave m pour brigade de
répression de l'action violente
motorisée
elle est facilement reconnaissable dans
les rues de Paris on va voir des images
voyez de du 18 mars dernier avec un
policier qui conduit qui ne fait pas de
maintien de l'ordre et qui est censé
uniquement se concentrer sur le pilotage
et à l'arrière un second policier qui
peut être rapidement déployé lorsque des
casseurs sont identifiés il doit
descendre de la moto pour intervenir
aujourd'hui ce sont 18 binômes qui
composent cette unité Thomas quand
a-t-elle été créé elle a été présentée
avec un nouveau dispositif de sécurité à
Paris en mars 2019 nous sommes alors le
jour de l'acte 19 des gilets jaunes et
une semaine après le saccage des
Champs-Élysées elles auront une capacité
de projection supérieure explique alors
le préfet de police de Paris Didier
l'allemand et cette brave m elle fait
polémique tout de suite parce qu'elle
rappelle les Voltigeurs de l'après mai
68 tout à fait oui même si aujourd'hui
les policiers ne peuvent plus intervenir
depuis leur moto et puisque c'est
Voltigeurs ont été dissous en 1986
après avoir causé la mort de Malikou
sekin on va avoir des images d'ailleurs
de l'hommage qui avait été rendu à
médicaux c'est Kin pour les 30 ans de sa
mort 1986 c'était en marge d'une
manifestation étudiante en tout cas
cette unité de brave m est accusé depuis
plusieurs jours d'avoir utilisé la force
de manière disproportionnée et même
certains de ses membres ont tenu des
propos très graves en marge
d'interpellation le 20 mars dernier je
peux te dire qu'on en a cassé des coudes
et des gueules mais toi je t'aurais bien
pété tes jambes à dire un fonctionnaire
enregistré par un manifestant ça a été
révélé dans cet article du Monde lui
rend le NES le préfet de police de Paris
a saisi l'IGPN la police des polices de
police suite à la publication de ses
propos mais il a dénoncé toute
comparaison entre la braven et les
Voltigeurs c'était ce matin sur France
Inter écoutez l'idée de maintien de
l'ordre formé pour ce faire la seule
différence c'est qu'ils sont très
mobilisent à moto pour pouvoir se rendre
plus vite d'un point à l'autre ce qui
est très utile contre des groupes contre
des groupes mobiles
la dissolution est pas l'ordre du jour
et ces unités sont nous sont précieuses
et c'est comparaisons en fait avec les
Voltigeurs sont sidérantes la dernière
information Thomas une pétition qui
demande la dissolution de cette unité a
déjà recueilli plus de 100000 signatures
c'est même près de 150 000 à l'heure on
se parle à partir de 500 000 paraphes
cette pétition provoquera un débat dans
la 5 de l'hémistique de l'Assemblée
nationale merci Quentin pour pour toutes
ces explications Laurent fagerman
comment vous expliquer que
dans les 8 premières journées de
mobilisation finalement globalement ça
se soit passé dans le calme ensuite il y
a le 49 ans on a bien on l'a expliqué
ici
comment ça ça provoque de la colère
peut-être de la violence et ça change la
nature du mouvement mais moi ce que j'ai
un peu de mal à comprendre c'est
pourquoi à la fois le le service d'ordre
syndical et puis les forces de l'ordre
n'y arrive pas d'un seul coup
alors il y a quand même sur la base à la
base un terreau c'est un immense
mécontentement on l'a un peu dit on l'a
esquissé mais ça c'est quand même
fondamental et donc dès les premières
manifestations même si elles étaient
calmes etc il y avait cette colère
extrêmement forte donc la bonne nouvelle
c'était des manifestations qui se
tenaient bien je pense parce que du
point de vue il y a aussi des groupes
organisés des groupes de casseurs je
sais pas comment les appeler autrement
et ces groupes là voyez bien que
politiquement c'était pas le moment pour
eux tout simplement c'est-à-dire que ils
étaient déjà présents mais c'était des
manifestations pacifiques l'espoir d'un
règlement pacifique de choses amour
absurdes de dialogue social que ça
puisse fonctionner et bien donc ça c'est
un espoir qui était chez les
manifestants et donc c'était pas le
moment pour eux tandisk à partir du
moment où il y a vraiment cette
accélération ce cheminement démocratique
et bien finalement vous avez il y a
l'espoir chez ce groupe d'entraîner une
partie des manifestants dans leurs
actions et ils avaient déjà réussi ça en
2016 sur la loi travail donc c'est pas
un exploration
cette cette question on a vu tout de
suite Emmanuel Macron voilà et
d'ailleurs c'est logique c'est que chef
de l'État se poser dans du côté de
l'ordre public
est-ce qu'il y a on se pose moi j'aime
pas du tout les discours évidemment
complotistes espèce de bière à trois
bandes on essaie de se dire ah tiens ça
va profiter un tel mais je vous pose
presque la même question
les forces de l'ordre qui s'en sortent
très bien pendant pendant 8 8 journées
là d'un seul coup son débordés parce que
d'un seul coup il y a 1500 personnes qui
débarquent à Paris et qui se forment
voilà en comment s'appelle Black Bloc
merci beaucoup il y a des jours où ça
m'échappe comment vous l'analysez vous
je pense que c'est parce que les
manifestants
c'est l'accumulation des journées sans
qu'il y ait un seul bouger jamais on a
vu des manifestations aussi importantes
en nombre je veux dire c'est ça 30 ans
qu'il y avait pas eu de manifestations
et je pense que c'est pour ça au bout
d'un moment il y avait ça et puis il y a
dans dans la rétine de la population et
notamment de ceux qui sont dans les
manifestations le fait que
que ça se passe bien ça ne provoque
aucun bougie de la part de
ça veut dire qu'il y a une sorte de
tolérance vis-à-vis de la violence ou de
participer à ce qu'on fait on fait
souvent la différence on aurait
manifestants d'un côté et les Black
Blocs de l'autre et l'ultra gauche de
l'autre sauf qu'on voit que de la de la
part de certains de manifestants il y a
une commande dire une
je cherche le mot comme vous Thomas mais
en fait une comment dire
voilà les gilets jaunes ça a été violent
ils ont obtenu des millions d'euros là
au bout d'un moment s'il faut en arriver
là pour être entendu voilà donc il y a
une espèce de de violence qui est
légitimée voilà le mot que je cherchais
une légitimation de la violence de la
part des gens qui qui eux sont enfin
manifestement enfin qui qui manifestent
en toute personne n'est jamais à l'aise
avec la violence c'est à dire que la
semaine dernière quand on faisait un
sondage là-dessus on avait une majorité
de Français qui nous disaient c'est
inacceptable c'est injustifiable mais
dans le même temps on avait 61% des
Français qui nous est c'est le seul
moyen de se faire entendre puisque le
gouvernement n'écoute pas les
manifestants pacifiques et c'est vrai
que le gouvernement a donné le mauvais
exemple on va dire avec les gilets
jaunes en disant on tient on tient on
tient on tient et puis tout d'un coup il
y a de la violence et on lâche on lâche
on lâche et on lâche beaucoup plus que
ce qu'on voulait prendre au départ enfin
si tu dis de manière un peu caricaturale
mais aujourd'hui on voit bien ça dans
l'opinion publique et ça doit permettre
aussi des groupes du coup se sentir
libre de pouvoir se lancer dans ce type
de de
manoeuvre parce que oui il y a comme une
forme de légitimation de l'opinion
publique à Paris comme dans les villes
de province on a vu ce mouvement était
très il y a un maillage territorial et
dans beaucoup de villes moyennes dernier
mot en conclusion l'immense majorité des
manifestants et veut rester pacifique et
c'est ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que si ça dérape peut-être
trop il y aurait plus de manifestations
dans la réalité c'est à dire qu'on
aurait plus le droit de manifester et ce
serait quasiment une coopération entre
les Black Blocs et les manifestants et
je voudrais dire aussi que cette
manifestation là à être passé calmement
dans la plupart des cortèges qu'à Paris
il y avait beaucoup plus de jeunes et
qui a pas eu plus de casse pour autant
autrement dit se faisant attention c'est
pas parce qu'il y a des jeunes qui
manifestent par exemple qui vont
forcément bien sûr être dans
l'agressivité bien sûr pas de pas
d'amalgame on essaie de évidemment les
les éviter au maximum et c'est vrai que
au moment où on parle en cette fin
d'après-midi il y a eu quelques heures
dans le cortège
parisien après le pillage d'un grand
magasin et l'intervention évidemment des
forces de l'ordre une vingtaine
d'interpellations à l'heure où l'on vous
parle merci à tous d'avoir participé à
ce premier débat